the gyro can experience well people find
great comfort in these belief systems it
gives them sort of I've often said that
it gives them some sort of like a
scaffolding for their just their
structure of the world their ethics
their morals they can use religion as
some sort of a mechanism to help them
get by something that they can climb on
to ease some of the confusion of the
unknown I'm sure that's true but I don't
understand why anybody
therefore thinks that therefore the
religion is true why would you think
that because it provides you with a
scaffold you can climb on that makes it
true I could understand you erecting a
scaffold that would say gymnastics or a
certain diet or something like that but
a belief about the universe that's how
that got to be true or not and it
doesn't make it true just because it's
comforting or provides you with a
scaffold to climb on well it's almost
like it's a spiritual system like a
placebo effect like a spiritual placebo
effect and by believing that this is
true it gives you this comfort and
allows you to condense your thoughts
into a better path the placebo effect of
course is very real and yes and doctors
know about it but did you know that the
perceiver effect works even if the
patient is told it's a placebo yes that
I don't get yeah it's very strange
well it's sometimes people doing things
and knowing that they're doing things
gives them this sort of feeling of
momentum of accomplishment of progress
and I think so many people are just so
adrift and don't have focus that even
just telling them hey we're gonna you're
gonna be a part of this program yes
program to treat XY disease whatever it
is and here's this thing like just just
focusing on it I think the main reason
why so many people believe in homeopathy
which which not only doesn't work but
cannot work is the perceiver effect then
they say well it's part of their gonna
get better anyway of course but it's
also the placebo effect that the
homeopathic I would say doctor
homeopathic practitioners
yeah gives them nonsensical piece of
medicine and they believe it's were
going to work and so it does and so the
placebo effect is important the CFI
central inquiry has actually got a
lawsuit going on at the moment against
pharmaceutical shops selling homeopathic
remedies alongside genuine ones hmm we
can't stop them actually selling
homeopathic remedies what we can try and
do is stop them putting them on the same
shelf as though there's no difference
but between them but my colleague Nick
Humphrey who's a psychologist very
insightful one things you could actually
even justify homeopathy on the grounds
that homeopathic practitioners are
allowed to prescribe placebos they call
them who me if I think that they are
placebos whereas real doctors are not
allowed to prescribe they used to real
doctors used to try placebos all the
time but they're now no longer allowed
to because it violates human rights but
homeopaths are allowed to a bizarrely
because they don't call them placebos if
they did they wouldn't be allowed to
well I have a similar thought about
chiropractic work chiropractors you know
do relieve pain from some for some
people but there's no reason why it
works
I would not be totally surprised if it
worked I don't haven't looked into it
enough I would absolutely be surprised
if homeopathy works it cannot work
because there's no active ingredient I
can't well wait to tell you the story of
chiropractic medicine that it was
created by a guy who is a magnetic
healer it was murdered by his own son
and his son took over the business and
started saying that it can cure
everything from leukemia at a heart
disease everything all by manipulating
the spine yes it was done in the 1800s
and there's no science behind it at all
but yet so many people have found pain
relief and chiropractors today it's
weird to lump them all in together but
many chiropractors today do do good work
because they incorporate legitimate
modalities in terms of like
rehabilitation like cold laser and all
these different massage remedies and all
these different things that actually
physically work
I know a woman who is a horse
chiropractor she does not cry but what
I'm trying to make is that whereas it's
a it's an empirical question whether
whether chiropractic works in the case
of homeopathy it cannot work because the
dilution is such that the there's
nothing there visiting there right
there's no chemical reagent one of
things they will they say it can work
because water has a memory but if they
could prove that water has a memory
they'd get the Nobel Prize for Physics
and they're not going to
[Applause]